bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro de kiosques qu'est ce que votre
magazine dédié à la culture sur saint
quentin en yvelines et ses environs tout
de suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 7
octobre
kaori ito célèbre chorégraphe japonaise
à l'art d'exprimer l'intimité son mot
elle est en plateau pour nous présenter
sa dernière création
je danse parce que je me méfie des mots
représentation au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les 14 et 15
octobre prochain à 20h30
jean-marc le rudulier maire de but qui
est jean tabary célèbre scénariste et
dessinateur de la bt iznogoud nous font
le plaisir d'être présent aujourd'hui
pour nous présenter le programme riche
et varié de la 22e édition du festival
de la bande dessinée de bus pu nous y
reviendrons dans quelques instants les
10 et 11 octobre prochains le centre des
monuments nationaux organise un
événement spécial monument jeu d'enfant
l'occasion pour les 5 12 ans de
découvrir la villa savoye de poissy le
domaine nationale de rambouillet le
château de maison à maison laffitte au
travers d'activités ludiques et
merveilleuse et nous démarrons notre
émission avec kaori ito célèbre
chorégraphe japonaise bonsoir kaori ito
vous êtes né à tokyo en 1979 fille du
célèbre sculpteur hiroshi ito vous
commencé la danse classique à l'âge de 5
ans formation que vous poursuivez
jusqu'à vos saisons à tokyo puis vous
partez à londres et aux etats unis avant
de vous installer à paris en 2003 vous
êtes amené à collaborer en europe avec
les plus grands noms de la danse prêche
jo cage platel tirer ainsi qu'avec deux
célèbres metteurs en scène au théâtre
comme denis podalydès et guy cassiers on
vous présente comme un prodige cas aurez
vous avez cherché à recréer une
rencontre lors de votre dernière
création avec votre père dans ce projet
une rencontre humaine et artistique
c'est ça oui pourquoi cette volonté de
de revenir sur une intime
et en prenant un peu le public à témoin
avec votre père parce que ça fait 13 ans
quand c'est pas reconnecté et pour des
racines
enfin pour des gens qu'ils ont déraciné
ça fait 13 ans que ces partis de japon
et je me suis culpabilisé le fait que
j'avais pas le dire avec mon pays avec
mon père est le fait de refaire un lien
avec moi avec mon père c'est comme si je
refais un lien avec le japon et vous
trouviez que avec l'expression du corps
c'était plus facile de d'entrée de
construire cette intimité simplement en
fait j'avais beaucoup de choses à dire
intimement qui ne se disent pas hors de
la scène parce que en fait c'est un
prétexte de spect enfin autant que
spectacle pour aller loin dans
l'intimité avec une sont deux témoins
des spectateurs prendre le public à
témoin une chorégraphie officielle
c'était plus facile pour vous pour
exprimer des choses des choses de
l'ordre de l'intimé c'est pas plus
facile je pense que c'est une manière de
s'exposer devant les gens on peut dire
que c'est en public donc c'est vrai que
mon père il voulait danser avec moi
cette fois que je suis rentré aux à pont
avec une musique de salon et au japon on
ne se touchent pas entraîner trop
famille donc on s'est dit que bon si on
veut faire ça on va faire ça sur scène
comme ça c'est clair
alors justement comment est-ce qu'on
aborde le travail chorégraphique on
danse avec son père comment est ce que
vous avez travaillé autour de ce projet
autour de ce projet où j'ai beaucoup
travaillé avec des questions sur mon
père qui était au début d'un lent dans
deux accusations en disant hey combien
de temps tu vas vivre encore et combien
de fois tu as dû te faire opérer
pourquoi tu fumes pourquoi tu pues
pourquoi tu vois de café à quelque chose
de spa se tromper ma mère pourquoi tu
vois plus des enfants de l'autre famille
donc il y avait quelque chose de l'aude
ronde accusations quand s'est posée et
par la réponse on fait la réponse est
sur la danse quand se communique son
élément il ya quelque chose de qui est
qui qui est très subtil entre dément qui
sous entend qu'on a une relation comme
ça sans parler et que ça ça peut
apporter des réponses par rapport à ça
mais il m'avait répondu à tous et de ces
questions que j'ai posées et les
enregistrer mais c'est par l'observation
l'un de l'autre que vous avez réussi à
construire cette chorégraphie ensemble
oui c'est de passer de temps semble déjà
parce que ça faisait longtemps et de
découvrir qu'en fait notre philosophie
de l'art est très proche donc on se
sentait très allié au tant qu'artiste et
pas peut-être autant que fille et père
mais entre aux fils et filles et perd il
y avait quelque chose aussi dans le sens
dans le sens d'un an 320 génétiquement
en attend revêt beaucoup de choses qui
sont comment peut on
on se méfie des mots par exemple on
passe par des gestes et qu on observe et
on écoute des gens et c'est la part des
gestes des gens quand trouve qu'il ya
une sorte de vérité dedans mais
justement ça a dû être difficile pour
votre père de se voir accuser par sa
fille comment est ce qu'il a il a abordé
au début ces accusations au début je
pense que on se posait pas de question
je pense qu'il voulait faire quelque
chose avec moins d un don qu'il a
commencé à aller à la gym pour
musculation du pin deux ans et il va
tous les jours donc il est content quand
même il a changé
je pense qu'il est dans cette mode
se confrontent r d de la peur et est-ce
que vous avez justement réussi à trouver
les réponses que vous étiez parti
chercher alors que vous aviez au départ
que votre père vous avez apporté mais
est ce que cette chorégraphie a répondu
à vos attentes
oui je pense qu'il y avait quelque chose
c'est le temps qui répondent à des
choses qui sont qui prend enfin c'est la
réponse est dans le temps et je pense
qu'il ya quelque chose que le fait qu'on
a partagé autant de temps pendant la
création
ça se voit corona on s'est entendu
quelque chose qui n'est pas qui n'est
pas visible mais c'est tout ce qui est
invisible qui est intéressant entre nous
kaori tout vous êtes japonaise vous
évoquez également justement la question
du déracinement de l'éloignement
culturelle dans ce spectacle vous
revenez en mars 2011 au japon
après dix ans d'absence et une semaine
après c'est le déferlement du tsunami
oui quels rapports que vous entretenez
justement à cette culture japonaise ce
pays un rapport conflictuel rapport de
culpabilité tout à l'heure vous disiez
il m'a d'abord j'avais cette culpabilité
de d'être sorti de mon pays mais après
pour les défunts des gens qui sont
expatriés c'est ça fait souvent ça le
fait seulement peur de revenir à la
place on est parti pour sentir ne pas
forcément tout ce qui est changée en
nous et dans ce pays où c'est plutôt de
de sentir tout ce qui n'est pas changé
en tant que japonaise en moi et au japon
et je pense que c'est des choses d
des phases de la vie qu'on doit
traverser en se déplaçant on peut faire
beaucoup de choses mais de revenir à la
place on est parti je pense qu'il ya
quelque chose à découvrir
et aujourd'hui vous êtes complètement
libéré de cette forme de culpabilité
culpabilité j'en ai pas je pense que
c'est parce qu'on en fait on est en
train de reconstruire notre identité en
est on se déplace on même on est parti
de lyon on est à paris fin on part de
chez un an par an de toutes façons
d'abord et on est de toute façon des
racines et parce qu'on a des pieds donc
il ya quelque chose de l'ain dans cet
ordre 2 de tomber la liberté de
construction de 93 identité on se
déplace on d'un lieu à l'autre qui
m'intéresse kaori ito merci d'être venu
c'est avec plaisir je rappelle que nous
vous retrouverons sur la scène du
théâtre de 50 ans les 14 et 15 octobre
ou prochain à 20h30 et sur paris on
pourra vous retrouver la ménagerie de
verre dans le cadre du festival
inaccoutumée les 11 et 12 décembre et du
30 au 2 avril au centquatre à paris et
nous passons à notre séquence festival
avec la 22e édition du festival de bd de
buc qui se déroulerait les onze les 10
et 11 octobre prochains
avant de retrouver en plateau nous
inviter je vous propose de découvrir le
portrait des rocs fameux scénariste
yvelines hauts de la bd les profs
également présent lors du festival image
d'elodie moines
il est l'auteur de la bande dessinée à
succès les profs 4 millions et demi
d'exemplaires vendus depuis 1998 mais il
se cache aussi derrière les scénarios de
cubitus
à 54 ans et rock de son vrai nom gilles
corre peut même s'enorgueillir d'avoir
reçu au début des années 2000 le prix
alpha art jeunesse au festival
d'angoulême scénariste de bd quand on
est enfant ce même pas que ça existe
c'est en gros je m'explique points pour
un enfant une bd s'est dessinée c'est
une belle histoire donc quand on quand
j'étais petit moi je voyais
j'adorais ça je lisais des bd je pensais
que c'était une seule personne qui
faisait les dessins etc inventé
l'histoire au fur et à mesure après
quand j'ai commencé à m'intéresser maman
la bd je me suis rendu compte
qu'effectivement ce qui m'intéressait le
plus moi dans la bd c'est d'être inventé
des histoires de raconter
donc j'ai commencé comme dessinateur
mais très vite dès que j'ai pu j'ai
écrit des histoires
les profs une source d'inspiration
permanente
il vient de signer le 17e album de sa
saga toujours avec bienveillance
pas question de se moquer du corps
enseignant mais plutôt de lui rendre
hommage
l'idée c'était des caricatures et mais
en bd de toute façon quand on caricature
les gens obligatoire - ils sont sympa
mais ça ça marche avec tous vous avez ça
dans les marionnettes des guignols c'est
la même chose quel que soit le le même
la charge peut être assez assez forte
sur un personnage à partir du moment où
ou ce personnage a un caractère
les gens s'y attache obligatoirement est
d'ailleurs moi je me rends bien compte
dans les profs les lecteurs préfèrent
les personnages les plus négatifs c'est
plus marrant obligatoirement et rock
sera présent au festival de la bd de buc
les 10 et 11 octobre pour des séances de
dédicaces
il assistera également à la projection
du film prof de vendredi à 19h30 au
théâtre des arcades de la ville
et on poursuit notre thématique festival
de la bd de buc avec nos invités qui
viennent d'arriver en plateau jean-marc
le rudulier maire de but que bon soir et
y voilà tabary célèbre dessinateur de la
bd iznogoud vous revenez tout juste
d'une séance de dédicaces à la
bibliothèque de bièvre hommes
bonsoir bonsoir alors comment s'est
passée cette séance dédicace je n'ai pas
arrêté
g j'ai commencé à rencontrer des enfants
d'un centre de loisirs donc de bièvre et
des enfants adorables et intéressés avec
plein de questions à poser
non ce qui n'est pas fréquent donc les
enfants souvent sont un petit peu
prostré et pose pas trop de questions
l'un puis les questions pertinentes
puisque ça a couvert un petit peu tout
toutes les questions que que même des
adultes peuvent se poser puis des
adultes étaient là aussi
et donc ils en ont profités ils ont
appris beaucoup de choses aussi grâce à
toutes les questions des enfants sur le
célèbre vizir fameux vous voilà avec
lequel on a tous grandi
jean-marc le rudulier adeptes du 9e art
alors ah oui adeptes du 9e art depuis 22
ans maintenant j'avoue niveaux créés non
non parce que justement j'ai démarré il
ya 22 ans parce qu'avant je connaissais
pas la bande dessinée c'est parce qu'on
l'a fait à buc je connaissais tintin
bien sûr comme tous les enfants et
astérix mais c'est tout ce que j'avais
vu des bandes dessinées et j'ai
découvert vraiment un univers très riche
de bandes dessinées et chaque année ma
porte de nous et je deviens un amateur
éclairé maintenant nicolas tabary vous
êtes le fils du légendaire jean tabary
qui nous a quittés en 2011 qui travaille
sur la série populaire iznogoud
alors d'abord aux côtés de rené goscinny
et puis par la suite tout seul iznogoud
ses 10 millions d'albums vendus dans le
monde une série qui a été traduite en 15
langues
alors vous avez vous même travaillé aux
côtés de votre père depuis vos 16 ans et
c'est à 11 ans qu'ils vont
de dessiner la première fois iznogoud
iznogoud c'est un personnage auquel vous
êtes nécessairement attaché quels
rapports que vous entretenez a nui à 10
ans que je suis née mois en plus l'année
où il ya eu deux premiers albums
d'iznogoud de publier en 66 et depuis
j'ai toujours regardé mon père
travailler dans sa dans son atelier et
donc j'ai été bercé par toutes ces
séries donc avec 10 noeuds good
j'ai forcément un rapport affectif fort
c'est un peu comme un frère de papier
finalement j'ai vécu à ses côtés comme
avec tous les autres personnages de mon
père comme totoche corinne et jeannot
est pendante un vagabond donc pas mal
pas mal de choses un univers vraiment
passionnant puisque j'étais fan de mon
père est gelé depuis le plus jeune âge
et d'ailleurs quand vous dites que à 11
ans j'ai eu gm a demandé de faire un
dessin 19 août c'est vrai que c'est mon
premier dessin 19 août publié dans un
album dans une histoire scénarisée à
l'époque par rené goscinny
c'était pour le besoin de l'histoire qui
voulait un mauvais desseins donc il
m'avait demandé et j'ai décidé snowgoons
et il a été publié il est dans l'album
toujours c'est l'album je veux être
calife à la place du calife
la dernière case de l'histoire le
revenant de la revue voilà d'accord
alors c'est un peu papier autrefois fils
de papier aujourd'hui peut-être ont pas
nécessairement un petit peu aussi
vraiment parce que je les jeux les
adopter gaudin
par la force du destin en fait le lien
que j'ai toujours entretenu avec mon
père et qu'il a entretenue avec moi j'en
a toujours été très très proches
et puis j'ai toujours dessiné j'ai
toujours été intéressé par ce qu'il
faisait et puis quand il m'avait demandé
à dix ans ce que je voulais faire plus
tard je vais dit je veux travailler avec
toi parce que j'aimais ce qu'il faisait
et jamais aussi le cadre de vie qu'il
avait avec ce métier ce cadre de vie
gelé aujourd'hui depuis maintenant pas
mal d'années pour la pub aussi parce que
je suis graphiste au départ et le destin
m'a emmené sur les traces de mon père
au niveau du personnage d'iznogoud d'
voilà donc on était tout une histoire de
famille quoi et alors la question qu'on
se pose n'est 7 ans et comment
faites-vous à chaque fois pour trouver
de nouveaux stratagèmes pour que cet
ignoble vizir aidé de son homme de main
cherchent à prendre la place du calife
de ce très bon canif d'abord vous
inspire disons que moi c'est le
personnage déjà le personnage c'est un
personnage extraordinaire pour un
dessinateur qui est extrêmement
expressif donc on peut tout lui faire
faire donc on s'ennuie pas c'est un
personnage qui peut tout jouer quand on
a un super acteur un louis de funès qui
explosent sans arrêt et puis qui devient
machiavélique donc donc assez
passionnant un peu comme un réalisateur
fin metteur en scène qui à son humble
acteur à qui demandent des choses et
qu'il réalise vraiment avec avec force
et vigueur
donc c'est vrai que ça fonctionne plutôt
pas mal
ce personnage est justement jean marc le
rudulier être calife à la place du
calife c'est plutôt une bonne métaphore
politique est ce que ça vous inspire
quelque chose alors là je vais vous dire
oui ça m'inspire quelque chose en ces
moments difficiles pour les mères ça me
dire que s'il veut vraiment ma place il
peut la prendre mais je suis pas sûr
qu'il ira jusqu'au bout mais c'est vrai
que être calife à la place du calife
c'est une expression qui est passé dans
le langage commun qu'on connaît tous
aujourd'hui nicolas tabary paraîtra
demain votre troisième album en
librairie demain jeudi
8 octobre l'album de père en fils alors
c'est un fils qui est rattachée à
l'histoire mais qui peut-être aussi pour
vous par rapport à votre père vient
consacrer justement un lien particulier
oui il ya une forme dans cet album une
forme de maturité et de comme si j'avais
passé un cap
j'ai eu mes deux premiers albums camp où
j'ai eu des difficultés pour déjà
prendre en main la série donc c'était
pas évident c'était pas gagné et c'est
album là j'ai trouvé mes marques dans la
façon de travailler avec le personnage
de faire de m'approprier les les dessins
des personnages et la couleur aussi à
laquelle j'ai participé ou mon père je
prononce mon père sicile hélas il me
regarde je pense qu'il doit être fier de
de la qualité que je mets vraiment au
service de la série et je veux faire
vraiment quelque chose de beau alors les
histoires c'est laurent vassilian qui a
repris le flambeau à tout seul cette
fois ci parce qu'il était quand nous la
dernière fois sur les goûts de président
et donc pour de père en fils il a il a
écrit ce scénario là donc sans titre
départ et le titre il est venu plus tard
c'est lui qui a eu l'idée de ce titre
qui finalement bizarrement tombe bien
pour l'histoire ce qui correspond bien à
l'histoire mais tombe bien aussi sur sur
le lien que j'ai depuis toujours avec
mon père et avec la création avec ses
séries in the woods en particulier ça a
été compliqué pour vos départements
répondre justement cette série qui était
lacéré de votre père disons que oui
c'était émouvant parce que les deux
premiers albums le premier jeu les jeux
les faits parce que mon père a eu un
accident vasculaire cérébral et s'est
retrouvée paralysée pouvait plus
travailler ils étaient aphasiques tour
ça a été vraiment un moment familial
difficile
ma mère un an après est décédé donc ça a
été vraiment une période difficile donc
on a fait cet album avec mon frère et ma
soeur au scénario dans une période
plutôt sombre et ensuite il ne goûte
président
j'ai démarré l'album mon père venait
après 6,7 en vraiment de difficulté à
vivre seul et avec le moral mais était
finalement dans une bulle à la fin à la
fin de sa vie et il est il est décédé en
août 2011 et je démarrais l'album
iznogoud président une semaine après
l'avoir enterré mon père donc fou ça a
été ça a été vraiment très très très
lourd la période pour démarrer aussi cet
album là donc peut-être que celui ci est
l'album où je me suis senti un peu plus
libéré peut-être de tous et toutes ces
émotions ou maintenant je me sens
vraiment un peu le père quand même du
personnage aujourd'hui donc demain
sortie de cet album et vous serez
également présent au festival de la bd
de buffle sur l'hygiène 10 et 11 octobre
je remarque que le rudulier est-ce que
vous avez des moments phare pendant ce
festival auquel vous tenez
particulièrement déjà c'est l'accueil de
tous nos dessinateurs puisque cette
année ses environs plus de 50
dessinateur qui vont venir
je crois que c'est un moment ça c'est un
moment très important pour nous mais il
ya les expositions qui sont également
des moments phares et puis il est tout
ce qui s'adresse aux enfants aux jeunes
enfants la dt le la possibilité de faire
une bande dessinée de et puis pour la
preuve enfin c'est long c'est la
troisième fois vendredi soir on projette
donc on a vu le film
les profs 2 avec la présence des rocks
qui sera là et rock a déjà travaillé
avec nous puisque il ya deux ans il a
travaillé beaucoup avec les enfants des
écoles et ils ont fait un ils ont sorti
une bd ma ville en bulles nous avons
consacré un reportage
donc je crois que ça ce sont des moments
phares et je crois que baron conduire
mais bon c'est la 22e édition
on espère que ça va encore continuer
humains positif c'est la même passion
c'est un rendez vous phare et depuis 94
quand même on a fêté les 20 ans il ya
deux ans on espère fêter les 30 ans des
quarante ans on verra bien mais je pense
que c'est un moment phare et puis on est
passé d'un d'un endroit on faisait
appeler la bande dessinée le salon
d'amande décidé dans le centre culturel
c'était devenu beaucoup trop petit on
est allé au château château qui a une
histoire puisque la bd de blake et
mortimer sos météores se passe
globalement à but et en particulier on y
voit le château et le château on y fait
la bd cette année et maintenant le
château n'est plus assez grand dont on
en rajoute une tente de 450 m² et puis
ce sera peut-être pas assez grand mais
on a mal à son corps dans le passé jean
que les signes d'un successeur tout à
fait jean-marc l'heureux dullier nicolas
tabary merci d'être venu sur notre
plateau et je rappelle donc on pourra
vous retrouver ce week-end pour des
séances de dédicaces 10 et 11 octobre au
château de buc et vous pourrez retrouver
la programmation complète du festival
sur ww point festival bd bucs est tirée
du cices mairie tirer but que point fr
toujours ce week-end le centre des
monuments nationaux organise la 17e
édition de monument jeu d'enfant
un rendez-vous pour permettre aux
enfants et leurs familles de venir
découvrir différents monuments nationaux
yvelinois au travers d'activités
ludiques et extraordinaire images de
patrick jacques de dixmude pour la 17e
édition de monument jeu d'enfant le
centre des monuments nationaux proposent
des activités destinées spécialement aux
jeunes publics les 10 et 11 octobre
prochains
partout en france et notamment dans les
yvelines une façon de sensibiliser les
familles au patrimoine architectural en
le rendant accessible
l'idée c'est de donner envie aux enfants
et à leur famille d'investir
notre monument et les monuments général
par un biais qui peut être ludique ou
merveilleux qui va peut-être être plus
attirant que une visite-conférence les
enfants de 5 à 12 ans sont invités à
remonter le temps au travers d'ateliers
divers et variés suivant les lieux danse
maquillage costumes peinture pendant ce
temps les accompagnateurs bénéficient de
tarifs réduits pour visiter les
monuments
j'aime beaucoup faire ça parce que ça ne
rappelle l'époque d'avant comment ils
s'habillent et la mode et c'est assez
drôle que nous les hommes on pas des
talons alors qu'elle en ait joueront
pour teva talent quand il faut sur
pattes et c'est les filles qui portent
des talons
cette année pour robots du mans jeu
d'enfant nous avons décidé de demander à
une chorégraphe de chercher ce qui
l'intéressait particulièrement en tant
que danseuse contemporaine et elle nous
a proposé de faire découvrir le le
bâtiment déjà dans un dans une sorte
première petite promenade marché et de
créer avec les enfants des danses ce
week end
des ateliers danse vous attendent à la
villa savoye de poissy et au château de
maison à maison laffitte et un atelier
laiterie bergerie au domaine nationale
de rambouillet sans transition nous
continuons notre programme avec notre
chronique cinéma que pensez-vous des
nouveautés de ce mercredi 7 octobre
vous aviez au micro de camille lambert
et nous avons beaucoup eux-mêmes donc
film très bien très bien fait très bien
exécuté et on vient de passer un très
bon moment à super brasseur et super
magnifique émouvant drôle frais envie de
le revoir déjà c'était très bien
c'était dans l'esprit prisoner
exactement donc pour ceux qui aiment pas
la violence ça se tenir voilà mais c'est
réaliste de mexico donc c'était super
bien très bon acteur mais trois équipes
références période dvlish del toro mais
bon c'était super bien donc conseillé
avoir vraiment à voir c'était très bien
c'était prenant et vu à la fin du film
on sait qu'il y en aura un troisième en
fait globalement c'était sympa quand
même un bon jeu d'acteurs vont après le
doublage français toujours moins bien
que 2 original on ne peut rien y faire
et j'ai quand même préféré le 1 parce
que le 1 était quand même beaucoup plus
axé sur ce qu'il est survie alors là
c'était plutôt un complot globale et
donc c'est un peu moins intéressant
cette semaine c'est marilyn pouls du
cinéma les yeux d'elsa de saint cyr
l'école qui nous donne son coup de coeur
sur les films à la fiche
prends moi d'octobre au cinéma les yeux
d'elsa de nombreux événements à
commencer par l'avant première de la
grèce et le ciel de films de luc jacquet
sur un pionnier de la glaciologie claude
lorius à travers ses expéditions en
antarctique donc la glace et le ciel en
avant première le 16 octobre avec la
venue d'anaïs orci qui est une bien ce
colloque est climatologue au cinéma les
yeux d'elsa en avant-première dans le
cadre d'un événement qui est
l'alternative à boisset fleurs avec le
17 et 18 octobre à fontenay le fleury
deux jours consacré donc aux aides aux
alternatives accompli ensuite on propose
une soirée animations le 17 octobre
avec bhutto naruto le film donc c'est la
suite de naruto avec le fils de naruto
et donc qui s'appelle le boru tôt et le
film miss hokusai en deuxième partie de
soirée qui est le portrait de
la fille du célèbre peintre hokusai donc
qui a travaillé à ses côtés et qui est
beaucoup moins connu que lui
voilà donc ça c'est la soirée
animations le 17 octobre et un autre
événement autour de l'animation avec
fantômes boy le 21 octobre avec un ciné
goûter animé donc fantôme boys est un
polar fantastique avec un personnage de
super héros qui allait le super pouvoir
de te transformer en fantôme et qui du
coup va résoudre une enquête policière
voilà j'ai fait tout pour les événements
du mois d'octobre au ciné malicieuse
elle ça en espérant vous retrouver
nombreux et comme chaque mercredi avant
de se quitter je vous propose quelques
dates à noter dans vos agendas
vendredi 9 octobre à 20h30 concert de
karimouche à la salle du scarabée de la
verrière un concert soul électro et rap
parsemé de musiques du monde
proposé dans le cadre du festival chance
automne samedi 10 octobre à 20h30 un
excellent plateau rap vous attend à la
batterie de guyancourt
ne manquez pas 10,6 esprit noir tito
prince et atik et enfin mardi 13 octobre
pour un moment littérature venez
rencontrer marie hélène lafon à 20h45 à
la clé des champs de plaisir auteur à
succès de joseph les pays et album fin
du fin du kiosque pour cette semaine
émission à voir et à revoir sur internet
je vous retrouve pour ma part avec
plaisir un mercredi prochain 14 octobre
très bonne semaine tous
m